in the world of A Song of Ice and Fire
and Game of Thrones various religions
have attempted to explain the nature of
reality in the religion of the drowned
God after death
his lawyer worshippers are said to feast
for eternity within the drowned God's
watery holes where they are served by
merlynx the Dothraki worshippers of the
horse God known as the great stallion in
the show believed that upon their death
their spirits will exist eternally in a
place known as the knight lands in the
worship of the seven death is
personified as the stranger who is
described as a hooded half-human
half-animal figure in the faith of the
seven it is said that the father took
stars from heaven and gave them to the
first king of the Andals there are also
believed to be seven hells many
different religions in the Song of Ice
and Fire and Game of Thrones offer
different ideas of what happens upon
death but is there evidence to support
any of these claims does the afterlife
actually exist in the a song of ice and
fire and/or Game of Thrones universes
long before men arrived in Westeros the
children of the forest lived
harmoniously with nature the where woods
were sacred to them according to some
legends it became a tradition of the
first men to place body parts and
entrails within the roots of the
weirwood trees even leading to rumors
and myths of man-eating trees the reason
behind this tradition seems to be that
it is possible upon death to transfer
one's consciousness into the weirwood
trees in a dance with dragons when asked
of the other children of the forest leaf
responds by telling bran that they were
now gone into the trees and in the
prologue their mere six skins after
dying beneath the weirwood tree can for
an instance see through the eyes of the
tree so where would trees do seem to
provide some kind of afterlife but this
type of afterlife is only applicable to
those that died near where woods what of
those that died nowhere near these trees
it is known that powerful skin changers
can live second lives through their
animals upon death but this only applies
to those with the ability to skin
is there evidence of an afterlife beyond
the where woods or the skin-changer
abilities the short answer is no in fact
the evidence says otherwise in the winds
of winter while under the influence of
the shade of the evening the same
substance which Danny took in a Clash of
Kings upon entering the house of the
undying the damp hair speaks to his
brother the long dead uragan do you know
what waits below the sea brother the
drowned God Aaron said the watery holds
Yuri shook his head was one so late Hugh
had the shade of the evening and a Song
of Ice and Fire
seems to provide an experience
reminiscent of the spice melange from
Frank Herbert's dune series not only can
one who frequently uses the substance be
identified by blue lips similar to the
blue eyes that mark spice addiction in
the dune series the substance seems to
pull back the veils of time and
understanding and show the truth of
reality this is why Danny in her visions
sees the past present and future
the visions show the truth of reality I
have come for the gift of truth Danny
said in the long haul the things I saw
were they true visions or lies past
things or things to come what did they
mean shape o shadow borrows no yet made
drink from the cup of ice drink from the
cup of fire mother of dragons child of
Maria
if the shade of the evening truly opens
one's consciousness to the true nature
of reality for uragan to tell the damp
air that only worms await him beneath
the sea is pretty telling in the show
there are also indications that a
conventional afterlife does not exist
when asked by Melisandre if he had seen
the other side beric Dondarrion replies
that he saw only darkness Jon Snow
responds similarly and is visibly shaken
by the realization that he saw nothing
upon dying we know that death and then
resurrection changes one beric
Dondarrion reports that he feels more
empty and Hollow upon each death and
resurrection in reality death is a
physical process upon death several
chemical processes begin to occur
including decomposition is it possible
that the changes people like Catelyn
Stark and beric Dondarrion have
experienced upon resurrection or the
results of physical changes instead of
spiritual ones the mind is a product of
the physical brain if the physical brain
is altered by the physical process of
dying and changes within the mind would
be inevitable with the evidence compiled
it seems greatly suggested in both the
books and the show that no afterlife
exists beyond the where woods and the
potential of a skin-changer to live
within his animal death appears foremost
within the world of Ice and Fire
to be a true end where only darkness
awaits
you